over the weekend the taliban
wheeling dealing gun running took over
the whole country again absolutely
pitiful to watch the taliban yesterday
here are two photos that we have of them
sitting in i believe this is the
presidential palace uh and as you can
see on the far left this guy's just
taking photos this is like influencers
in the wild for terrorists and criminals
they're literally posing for photos to
be posted on the internet as propaganda
then you can also see we've got a second
photo of them sitting there guess what
those are not ak-47s on the right that
looks like an m4 with a collapsible
combat buttstock
what the guy in the middle he also has a
m4 the guy sitting second to the left or
standing second to the left that looks
like he also has an m4 an m16 where are
they getting m4s and m16s oh they have
american weapons
that's where they're getting it from but
it's not just rifles we scoured the
internet the best business show research
team we outsource globally to people all
over twitter go find us great
information go find us great photos and
content
and we'll bring it on here and we'll
give you credit for it election wizard
literally a guy's name on twitter
he posted a photo hearing unconfirmed
reports that the taliban has captured
several scan eagle drones valued at 3.2
million dollars i have no clue if the
taliban knows how to fly drones but i
know that they got the drones i saw
other videos of them literally driving
around with the boxes and the drones in
them literally showing the drones
closing the box and taking off with them
and so we'd literally have millions of
dollars in one piece of equipment
falling into the taliban's hand but it's
not
just the drones i want you to watch this
video that we're about to play
and you tell me
what is going on the taliban has
helicopters
they have helicopters now here's a video
oh there's some more yup we just got
some out back too
all right we're good they got
helicopters they've got drones they've
got rifles they got all kinds of
equipment they have humvees they have
mraps mine resistant armor protected
vehicles they have everything that we
left behind i don't give a [ __ ] what
your politics are i don't care what you
think about this president the last
president the next president i don't
care about any of it all i know is that
the cost of war is incredibly high
there is no reason
why we both gave life of soldiers of
afghan interpreters of family members of
defense contractors etc and 20 years
later the taliban in a span of two weeks
literally the time that the u.s
government told us to flatten the curve
it took
for the taliban to go from the mountains
to controlling the entire country they
took the first second third and fourth
largest cities in a span of one week
absolutely insane so what do we do on
the best business show we do exactly
what nobody will do anywhere else who's
making money on all of this well
the first problem that we have is nobody
can agree on how much money was spent on
the war in afghanistan or the war in
iraq we've been there for 20 years
and our calculators are broken the u.s
government says that we spent a couple
hundred billion dollars in afghanistan
about 800 billion dollars is their
estimate
if you look at what is it the war uh
what is this the harvard it's the
harvard study or brown brown brown the
total cost of wars uh is estimated to be
about three trillion dollars
and then we've seen estimations as high
as six trillion dollars is it 800
billion is it 6 trillion nobody knows if
we don't know how much money we spent
how can we possibly know where the
equipment is what equipment there is how
will
we find it all out we don't know but you
do you know who's been making money the
defense contractor so
the best business show research team
dug in
the top 10 defense contractors here they
are lockheed martin
makes 96 of their revenue from defense
contracting
raytheon
65 of their revenue comes from the
defense industry boeing over 50 percent
of boeing comes from the defense
industry northrop grumman 85
general dynamics 79
and do you know who has two of the top
10 defense contractors in the world
china china north industries
literally has
15 billion dollars in defense revenue
and china's state shipbuilding
corporation has 13 billion dollars in
2020 defense revenue absolutely insane
to see the size of these businesses so
again you want to have the conversation
no one's going to have well what
happened over the last 20 years the s p
500 has rallied
from uh let's see this this is way too
small for my old eyes from about 116
to 443 let's call it give or take about
400
increase in price
that's the smp
the benchmark for the stock market well
i wanted to go see what the defense
contractors do
lockheed martin went from one or uh went
from 38 bucks
38 dollars to 357
the s p went up 400 percent and lockheed
martin went up 10x
give or take
they really outperformed the smp
well it wasn't just lockheed though if
we then look at raytheon raytheon went
from about twenty one dollars to today's
exit 86 and that is after
covid had a massive negative impact on
the business still has not reached back
to that all-time high at almost 100
21 to 86 doesn't sound so bad
but then we looked at boeing and boeing
got decimated by covid but even though
it got decimated it's still gone from 51
to 228 dollars and so ultimately what we
have to remember is that there are
multiple complexities at play here the
first complexity is that these defense
contractors are booking tens of billions
of dollars in revenue for defense
contracts some of it is justified and
some of it is absolute nonsense who
knows who can decide there is no one
because we don't even know how much
money was spent on the wars in
afghanistan and iraq on top of that what
we find is that some of the businesses
have absolutely exploded in stock price
and some of them have gone sideways the
deeper concentration you had in the
defense industry the higher the stock
price went if you had over 90 percent of
your revenue coming from the defense
industry
war is good for business and those
businesses took off that is what is
happening and so now what we're seeing
is
hundreds of millions maybe billions of
dollars maybe a trillion dollars worse
worth of defense equipment has been
abandoned in a country that we spent the
last 20 years trying to nation build
and now it has fallen into the hands of
the taliban
and what you ultimately find is that
the government for the most part put up
no fight
from the afghanistan perspective the
president fled most people put down
their guns and the taliban walked right
in there are people in kabul right now
who are literally on the tarmac trying
to get on a plane to get their wives and
their daughters
or themselves out
of that country
that is what true fear and evil looks
like
and so what we have to remember is the
business impact here almost doesn't
matter but at the same time that the
business impact doesn't matter
the businesses have been popping
what do you guys think about seeing
videos and photos
of the taliban literally posing like
instagram influencers in the
presidential palace and then they've got
these
drones humvees helicopters etc they're
taunting us right like to some degree
they're they're they obviously think
it's a joke right like they're i saw a
video of them working out in the gym or
whatever and they're doing curls doing
all sorts of stuff just ridiculous uh
photos and images uh and videos coming
out of there but i think when you look
at it like
just look at the facts right the
government's saying that we spent 800
billion dollars that's a joke that's not
even close to believable no one i don't
think in their right mind believes that
that's actually how much we spent there
most uh real estates from economists and
other organizations that study this
stuff for a living estimate it was
somewhere between anywhere from two and
a half trillion to six trillion dollars
so uh significantly significantly more
than the government has admitted to
spending and then you just look at it
from the perspective of where were we
and where are we now right we entered 20
years ago and we leave 20 years later we
spent billions of dollars trying to
build up their government and give them
a democratic process and we leave 20
years later
with them having billions of dollars of
equipment not only military equipment
right but they also uh hundreds of
thousands of people have died or been
injured both uh citizens within
afghanistan and us military forces and
the taliban is in charge again right so
just from the simple perspective of like
where we entered and where we are now uh
politics aside you can always get into
the purpose of it uh who benefited all
this kind of stuff but we're no better
off necessarily than we were previously
with people uh the people that we left
in charge and the system and the money
that we spent completely agree do they
know how to operate that drone can they
fly the helicopters no
no these are gonna i mean they're gonna
try it's know until they do it yeah it's
know until they learn until you see it
in this until they're trained on it yeah
right yeah yeah to be fair i don't think
uh it's always no and i think that
there's probably some ways that they'll
learn that they'll teach themselves or
someone will be like that you know stunt
person to go and try it out uh but i
would
i'm pretty certain there's no way one of
them is picking that up and like
intuitively figuring out how to work
that a u.s soldier
that's untrained the u.s soldier that's
untrained isn't picking it up and flying
it yeah so definitely not here
do we think about the idea of the
taliban being in control now one of my
fears is that other countries around the
world we already saw china step this up
start saying to hong kong hey when the
u.s says we stand with hong kong they
don't stand with [ __ ] they abandon their
allies they literally ran with their
tail between their legs and got out of
the country as fast as they could and
they literally left
what's estimated to be 50 000
afghans and their families who helped
the united states during the last 20
years
do we see
adversarial countries start to step it
up and say hong kong taiwan etc other
countries like that uh or other areas
that are under immense pressure where
the u.s has protected them via this kind
of uh u.s
kind of military might
does that now does that bluff get called
do we do we see china go start to
pressure hong kong and say the u.s ain't
coming the us doesn't stand with you or
taiwan or something like that
we could right like what have you done
for me lately if this is kind of the
precedence that we're gonna set uh
certainly
it just depends right like if someone's
wanna call that bluff or not
they're sitting in the president's
palace on al jazeera
holding american weapons after they just
stormed their country yeah the taliban
controls more of afghanistan today than
they did 20 years ago
that is a wild stat not to mention
everything that happened in between
the taliban controls more of afghanistan
today than they did 20 years ago and
we've spent
trillions at least i don't care what
they're saying trillions
on fighting this war thousands of
americans died
and there's a lot of people asking
why
one thing i want to bring up is who's
paying for it right so we talk about
them spending trillions they don't have
an estimate of course the us estimates
is super low but the national priorities
project has it at 5.4 trillion since
2001 that we've spent on war that would
mean that every hour taxpayers in the
united states are paying 32 million
dollars for war every hour the u.s the
pentagon itself has stated in 2019 that
through the fiscal year so the u.s
government's fiscal year is from october
1st through september 30th
the pentagon estimate that wars in
afghanistan iraq and syria have cost
each taxpayer 7 700 bucks in 2018. so
each person paid 7 700 bucks for war
hope you got your money's worth
right and that's crazy yeah not not to
mention that the uh total debt per
citizen is like 85 000 and the total
federal tax income per citizen is like
11 000. so we're already at like a three
to one deficit there
the reason why i brought the defense
contract is not only because nobody will
go and talk about that on mainstream
television uh but two is
i think it would be incredibly difficult
to convince this generation of americans
to go to the next war
right after they've seen what happened
in afghanistan and iraq if the u.s
government said came to us and said so
and so whatever country whatever group
they're bad people we're gonna go to war
i don't think a lot of people would say
i like that idea i don't think a lot of
people would say let's do it i don't
think a lot of people would say let me
send my son or daughter to the front
lines
and so all of a sudden i don't think
that the defense industry is going to
contract and get smaller
but i do think that these companies have
a major tailwind in front of them in the
fact that
if you're not churning out humvees and
blackhawk helicopters and drones and
missiles and bullets and ar-15s
then what exactly are you gonna be
selling hey guys thanks so much for
watching that clip of the best business
show make sure you like and subscribe to
the channel turn on notifications so you
know when we go live every weekday and
then head to sofi.com so that you can
get an account we can get after it